deux matches deux victoires pour les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux ce
dimanche contre les deux filles dogs de
st juste pour le compte de la 4e journée
du championnat de première division les
signé mon teint se sont imposés à
domicile 9 à 2 dans la première
rencontre et 13 à 7 dans la seconde je
pense qu'on a fait un bon match a
atteint notre objectif
que ce soit personnel ou pour l'équipe
tout le monde est content aujourd'hui
plutôt positif même si on a deux trois
petites choses à corriger en tire encore
à l'entraînement et puis ça devrait
aller c'était vraiment un match
comment on dit de préparation parce que
voilà on voulait c'est une équipe qui
valait beaucoup de base afin qu'ils
avaient l'intention vraiment devenir
pour pour gagner et on s'était un match
test c'était vraiment aussi aujourd'hui
une journée test parce que voilà si on
les gagne pas on aura eu des problèmes
au crès je pense mentalement aussi
c'était vraiment important pour ça de
gagner contre cette équipe-là avec cette
victoire montigny premiers du
championnat à égalité de points avec
l'équipe fédérale de toulouse les deux
équipes affichent un bilan de cinq
victoires et une seule défaite depuis le
début de la saison les statistiques
digne d'un prétendant à la montée en
première division
on prend toujours les match par match a
vraiment les victoires vu par victoire
on va pas s'emballer on reste serein on
reste la tête faut garder la tête froide
pour l'instant la défense et notre
objectif maintenant on a encore beaucoup
de chemin à faire et qu'on n'a pas
affronté tout le monde encore on a un
bon objectif on a un bon collectif donc
je pense que c'est faisable
prochain match pour montigny le
bretonneux le dimanche 15 mai sur le
terrain de la rochelle une équipe
invaincue à domicile 1